the year is 1988 big hair and denim are
in the ultimate lead singer and hair
metal Kiplinger and his band are at the
top of the charts but the party that
seemed like it would never end suddenly
came crashing down
no airplay no singles nothing but it
turns out this was just the beginning
for Kip Winger this is you know at home
with Kip Winger I'm Chris funk I'm a
musician in a band called The
Decemberists and I'm on a journey
looking for the most surprising and
extraordinary people in music my next
stop takes me to nashville tennessee
there I will meet a rock legend with one
of the most unexpected transformations
in music
The Decemberists tour brought me to
Nashville where we played the historic
Ryman theater a day between shows gave
me a chance to explore the city known
for its honky tonks and live shows
[Music]
but I was here for something else to
track down an 80s icon hello
I'm Kip Winger and I'm in the band
winger and I'm also a classical composer
at the height of my career we were
playing for thousands of people every
night and gold and platinum albums
beavis and butt-head was the biggest
show in MTV's history at the time and it
occurred in a whole new genre of music
grunge and it completely ripped apart
the 80s hair bands and I was at the
scene of the crime my name was on the
little geeky guys t-shirt that
represented everything that sucked lost
the record deal lost the publishing I
was at my very lowest point I did say
well there's nothing else to do now
except that thing that I've always
wanted to do which is really learn how
to wield an orchestra organically
[Music]
to go from a rock bass player to
composer is learning music all over
again to do so later in life is Kip did
is almost unheard of
[Music]
I could never even read an orchestral
score until I was 35 10-15 years into it
to finally start to hear orchestras play
my music and realize oh my god this is
really what I'm here to be doing that's
awesome that's amazing in this case I
took a I'm calling it a riff because
that's my terminology from being a rock
guy
[Music]
by the dead that turns into
it was a scary and lonely path I've got
a record company that's going why are
you doing that you're a rocker you need
to rock and I'm like nah nah no I don't
need to rock I need to be doing this
this kind of starts all in a rock riff
really you know you kind of go against
all odds when you just believe in
something
despite the challenges with learning how
to compose Kip's persistence ultimately
led to a Grammy nomination in
contemporary classical composition
it's very cathartic healing experience
to overcome my illiteracy and music at a
late age with not so much
self-confidence it was like okay you
know what I don't suck like it wasn't
true what they all said to be
acknowledged with a composure nomination
from the Grammys was the greatest
feeling of accomplishment of my whole
life
[Music]
[Music]
you